après un noël marqué l'année dernière
par la crise sanitaire la course aux
cadeaux et aux jouets est bel et bien
lancée malgré quelques ruptures de stock
la pénurie due à des retards de
livraison n'a finalement pas eu lieu et
selon l'enseigne king jouet 56 % des
parents ont déjà commencé leur premier
achat on n'a aucune contrainte cette
année particulière duo covit comme
l'année dernière juste comme ça donc
cette année les gens sont au rendez vous
la magie rendez vous donc le tour est
passé parfaitement cette année sous le
sapin les héros reprennent du service
dans les grandes tendances on retrouve
les jouets harry potter marvel ou encore
pas de patrouille qui connaît un très
grand succès auprès des tout-petits
depuis la sortie du film cet été au
cinéma alors pendant un stoner est
grande avec ray est dangereux car vous
allez trouver tous les produits harry
potter sera en fête les 25 ans de
l'univers vous allez avoir tout ce qui
est pas de patrouille les sens pas trop
ils y sont fortes en fait de manière
générale cette année tous les super
héros avec trimark sorte lors des
différents confinement les familles ont
passé plus de temps à jouer ensemble les
jeux de société et les puzzles se
retrouve donc en bonne place dans les
rayons tout comme les jouets éthique et
éco-responsable qui gagne du terrain
chaque année je sais pas en regardant
par quelque chose qui est en bois qui en
a tout l'air qu'ils ne contiennent pas
des et des produits nocifs des pâtes
panther et tout ça et malgré la hausse
des prix des matières premières à cause
du transport les jouets ne seront pas
tous impacté de la même façon une
situation qui profite aux jouets
français ils représentent 15% des ventes
globales depuis le début de l'année on
retrouve par exemple l'indémodable
sophie la girafe décliné en peluches
doudous ou jouer ludique